bonjour alexis troude merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct tôt ce matin
le kosovo on le rappelle est reconnu par
100 pays des nations unies l'onu qui
compte 193 membres
bruxelles dit vouloir favoriser une
désescalade détention washington de son
côté s'est aussi invitée dans le
dialogue fin juin avec une approche plus
économique
pourquoi le kosovo est il si stratégique
alors comme bledi le kosovo est reconnu
tu pars de moins en moins pays vous avez
10 en pays nantais 93 pays 1 grâce à
l'action du ministre serbe des affaires
étrangères
le nombre de pays qui reconnaissent
kosovo et c'est un fait historique est
en train de baisser il est passé de 109
il ya deux ans à 93 pays les plus grands
pays au monde ne le reconnaissent pas la
russie la chine les plus grands pays
musulmans l'egypte l'indonésie
donc bon ça c'est un fait actuel assez
intéressant c'est à dire que même dans
l'union européenne
très peu de pays
reconnaisse le kosovo alors pourquoi
c'est un point névralgique parce que
c'est un poids d'abcès en europe
c'est une un trou noir comme le disent
les meilleurs spécialiste en
géopolitique un trou noir en europe qui
qui accumule les handicaps entre chômage
explosif rhein de la mafia et trafics en
tout genre et c'est pour ça que l'union
européenne comme les états unis veulent
reprendre la main et veulent absolument
arrêter
l'aps est un thème s'est ouvert au coeur
de l'europe mais ils ont quelque chose à
y gagner
alors pourrait voir cette question je
vais essayer de très rapide
le kosovo en fait quand il ya eu les
premières bombes qui sont tombées en au
mois de mars 1999 tout le monde se
posait question est pourquoi on se
souvient les jospin qui parlait du droit
humanitaire
un tony blair qui poussaient des cris
d'orfraie contre le pouvoir serbe en
fait dès les premiers jours
la société américaine halliburton
possédée par un certain dick cheney
creusé avec ses pelleteuse le sol du
kosovo pourquoi le kosovo c'est tout
simplement la deuxième réserve de
lignite au monde des métaux rares très
important et donc c'est ça qui explique
le l'appétit si vous voulez vorace des
compagnies internationales pour que
souvent quand on est sur place on voit
très bien il ya énormément de
représentants de ces compagnies qui
cherche la deuxième raison c'est que
qu'aux se trouve à l'intersection des
fameux corridor savez les corridors ce
sont la conjonction à la fois
d'autoroute de gazoduc de l'eau duc donc
des fameux corridor européen le 8 le 4
et 10 plus des corridors américain le
projet nabucco est maintenant des
corridors de la soie chinoise et donc
qui est un jeu très fort entre les états
unis l'europe et la chine sur ce petit
territoire en europe qui regorge de
richesses du sol et du sous-sol et si
vous laissez ça en géopolitique qui
explique l'attrait du kosovo et c'est
pas pour rien que les américains y ont
installé leurs principales bases
à l'extérieur des états unis la base de
bondsteel où pas moins de 7000 soldats
stationnés en permanence
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de
cette visioconférence aujourd'hui
organisée à l'initiative d'emmanuel
macro et et que faut qu'ils attendent un
gagnant de la rencontre dimanche à
bruxelles entre aleksandar vucic le
président de la serbie et abdullah
outils le premier ministre du kosovo à
grand chose
je vais expliquer pourquoi en fait ces
fameuses négociations qu'on appelle la
négociation les normalisations ont
commencé dès 2013 ce qu'on a appelé le
coprolite belgrade depuis 2013 sous
l'égide de l'union européenne
les dirigeants serbes et les dirigeants
du kosovo négocier ardemment avec des
hauts et des bas or il faut savoir que
les deux les deux partenaires finalement
sont très affaiblis comme les très bien
répéter tout à l'heure les albanais sont
très affaiblis puisque leur président
hashim thaçi et le premier ministre sont
sous le coup d'une impulsion d'une
inculpation par le très bien spéciale
pour le kosovo mais la partie serbe est
aussi très affaibli puisque présent vous
de fitch qui est actuellement à belgrade
aux côtés de macron est en train de
faire face dans la rue à des
manifestations importantes depuis trois
jours et donc ses deux partenaires qui
sont affaiblis vont avoir intérêt à
freiner encore ces négociations et à ne
pas avoir ne pas prendre les décisions
importantes de leur côté
emmanuel macron ou un galet merkel
veulent absolument négocier cette
question du kosovo mais ils savent très
bien que ils ont de moins en moins de
deux pouvoirs face aux deux autres
puissances sur place qui sont la chine
et les états unis
or les établissements et bien veulent
absolument se débarrasser du pain du
kosovo puisque les etats-unis ont un
plan pour est bien petit à petit faire
que les soldats américains partent de la
base de mon style et les chinois eux ne
veulent pas entendre parler d'une
indépendance du kosovo
de la même façon pérusse d'ailleurs les
chinois qui sont très présents sur le
terrain donc je pense que on ne va pas
voir avant longtemps
un règlement de cette question en tout
cas pas avant plusieurs mois cette année
alors vous dites qu'on se dirige vers un
statu quo pour pour au final c'est le
statut final qui est en jeu du kosovo et
alors pourquoi une rencontre par
visioconférence aujourd'hui pourquoi une
rencontre dimanche entre les deux hommes
forts de chaque partie pourquoi est-ce
que si on ne va pas avancé pour qu'on se
rencontre quand même et pourquoi
maintenant c'est quoi la logique la
logique actuelle c'est le calendrier
politique de toutes parts calendrier
politique des états unis de la trump
essaye de se débarrasser de certains
problèmes notamment kosovo je viens de
vous dire en se désengageant totalement
et je ne vois pas de l'ain trump
soutenir celui qui était jusqu'à son
allié c'est à dire les albanais il faut
rappeler aux auditeurs que quand vous
dès que vous mettez les pieds à
l'aéroport de pristina
vous êtes comme dans une province
américaine vos images de montrer tout à
l'heure des monuments un modèle bright
des burger king par tous unis dans des
universités américaines et donc les
américains après qui jusque-là soutenait
le kosovo ont décidé se sont
ont changé de politique ont décidé de ne
plus soutenir ben c'était à mafieux
finalement et jusqu'à dirigé par exemple
siens et guérilleros de loot chez capcom
hashim thaçi l'union européenne elle
voudrait on sent une volonté de la part
des mâles macron et d'engrais merkel de
régler cette situation mais n'a pas de
plan alors il ya eu beaucoup de temps
aujourd'hui mais il ya eu plusieurs
plans il y avait les plans de
cantonalisation comme pour la bosnie il
y à eut abandonné un plan de partage du
territoire entre nord et sud
mais aucun de ces plans quand vous
écoutez les déclarations de des
chancelleries européennes ne sont
proposées aujourd'hui donc on voit bien
là que l'union européenne est en train
de présenter cette problème du kosovo
uniquement par rapport à son opinion
mais ne peut pas sur ses marges sud est
puisque c'est en dehors de son
territoire finalement le kosovo c'est
encore dans ce qu'on appelle le trou
noir d'europe et donc n'a pas la main
véritablement pour régler cette question
là si la chine ce film est très
intéressé par un statu quo puisque la
chine et ce pays qui depuis quelques
années a investi énormément notamment en
serbie en macédoine 11,0 et la chine n'a
pas intérêt à ce que les frontières
change pour le moment merci merci à
l'escroc d'avoir répondu à nos questions
pour ce décryptage de nous avoir éclairé
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur en
géographie en géopolitique et
spécialiste des balkans auteur notamment
de les balkans un éclatement programmé
aux éditions xenia